Jake: 开始吧开始吧
Jake: Let's start, let's start.
Jake: 大家互相看一下谁的红灯
Jake: Everyone, check who has the red light.
Jake: 白灯没有亮就是
Jake: If the white light isn't on...
Katrina: 亮了
Katrina: It's on.
Shure: 都亮了
Shure: They're all on.
Jake: 亮了很亮很亮
Jake: It's on, very on, very on.
Jake: 来看一会
Jake: Let's take a look for a bit.
Lucia: OK
Lucia: OK.
Jake: 好看吗
Jake: Is it nice?
Shure:  好看
Shure: It's nice.
Shure:  太棒了
Shure: It's awesome.
Jake: 好看
Jake: Nice.
Alice: 好看
Alice: Nice.
Jake: 好看
Jake: Nice.
Tasha: 自己想看
Tasha: Want to see for myself.
Jake:评论评论评论
Jake: Comment, comment, comment.
Jake: 这谁啊
Jake: Who is this?
Shure: 陈泽啊
Shure: It's Chen Ze.
Katrina:  呵呵陈泽有点抽象真的
Katrina: Haha, Chen Ze is a bit abstract, really.
Jake:说你整我呢
Jake: Saying you're messing with me.
Jake: 天天小考
Jake: Daily quizzes.
Katrina:  哎呀
Katrina: Oh no.
Shure: 成谢谢您
Shure: Alright, thank you.
Jake: 好好嘞
Jake: Okay, okay.
Jake: 哎呀
Jake: Oh no.
Shure:  掉出来了
Shure: It fell out.
Jake: 哎呀怎么掉出来了
Jake: Oh no, how did it fall out?
Lucia: 好谢谢
Lucia: Alright, thank you.
Katrina: 呀好热呀
Katrina: Ah, it's so hot.
Katrina:  感觉比武汉还热呀
Katrina: Feels hotter than Wuhan.
Jake: 会是老板第一个下车
Jake: Will the boss be the first to get out?
Jake: 一般老板是第一个下车吗
Jake: Is the boss usually the first to get out?
Shure:  不知道
Shure: I don't know.
Lucia: 不是应该先
Alice:公主请下车哎呦
Alice: Princess, please get out... Oh my.
Tasha: 浪费下车
Tasha: Waste of getting out.
Shure:  万一遇刺什么的是吧
Shure: What if there's an assassination, right?
Jake: 对第一个下车第一个被崩
Jake: Yeah, the first to get out, the first to get shot.
Shure: 第一个下了之后喽
Shure: Once the first is out...
Shure:  保镖
Shure: The bodyguard.
Jake: 怎么过去啊
Jake: How do we get over there?
Jake: 怎么停在这么个地方啊
Jake: Why did we stop in such a place?
Katrina: 怎么过去
Katrina: How do we get over?
Tasha: 跨过去
Tasha: Just step over.
Shure: 我们只要
Shure: We just need to...
Jake: 你跨一下
Jake: You step over.
Shure: 助跑一下
Shure: Take a running start.
Lucia: 助跑一下哈哈哈
Lucia: Take a running start, hahaha.
Shure:  迟到了
Shure: We’re late.
Alice:不太好
Alice: Not good.
Jake: 咋整啊
Jake: What do we do?
Jake: 那边是可以走吗
Jake: Can we go that way?
Shure: 过去
Katrina:  盒马在这个商场里吗
Katrina: Is Hema in this mall?
Jake:那那那过得去吗
Jake: Can we get through there?
Jake: 过不去
Jake: We can't get through.
Tasha: 盒马在哪
Tasha: Where’s Hema?
Jake: 绕一圈吧
Jake: Let’s circle around.
Tasha: 真的可以过去的
Tasha: We can really get through there.
Jake: 问问吧
Jake: Let’s ask.
Shure: 盒马
Lucia: 那个有点高吧感觉跨不过去啊
Lucia: That looks a bit high, I don't think we can get over it.
Shure:  师傅那个盒马鲜生在哪
Shure: Sir, where is the Hema Fresh store?
Shure:  从从这边绕过去是吗
Shure: Do we go around this way?
Jake: 这个行人还得这么绕
Jake: Pedestrians have to go all the way around?
Lucia: 哎不是
Lucia: Hey, wait a minute.
Lucia: 等一下同志们
Lucia: Hold on, everyone.
Lucia: 腿长的人已经先过去了
Lucia: Those with long legs have already gone over.
Lucia: 呵呵是这是是是
Lucia: Haha, yes, this is...
Shure:  这这边绕一下吧
Shure: Let's go around this way.
Shure:  还是
Shure: Or...
Katrina: 这边过去
Katrina: Let's go this way.
Katrina:  在那边
Katrina: Over there.
Shure:  对走吧走吧
Shure: Yeah, let's go, let's go.
Jake: 头盔要不给他吧
Jake: Should we give him a helmet?
Jake: 他跑过了
Jake: He ran over.
Tasha: 我伤心了
Tasha: I'm sad.
Alice:这我穿裤子
Alice: I'll put on pants.
Alice:行
Alice: Alright.
Alice:咋啦
Alice: What's up?
Tasha: 我的钻石掉了
Tasha: My diamond fell off.
Alice: 底下那个底掉了没法往上弄了
Alice: The base fell off, can't fix it back up.
Tasha: 对啊
Tasha: Yeah.
Alice:不闪了
Alice: It's not sparkling anymore.
Jake:来带大家看看这个
Jake: Let's take a look at this.
Jake:北京大超市
Jake: A big supermarket in Beijing.
Jake: 他们已经上去了
Jake: They already went up.
Tasha: 为什么不等我们
Tasha: Why didn't they wait for us?
Jake: 这么快的
Jake: So quick.
Jake: 他们是上去了
Jake: They went up.
Tasha: 是吧
Tasha: Right?
Jake: 这怎么上来这么快啊
Jake: How did they get up so fast?
Lucia: 你们怎么已经到了啊
Lucia: How did you guys get here already?
Jake: 我们还找你们呢
Jake: We were still looking for you.
Jake: 怎么丢了呀
Jake: How did you get lost?
Katrina:  系了个鞋带而已
Katrina: Just tying a shoelace.
Shure:  我们我们跟着轩导的步伐来着
Shure: We were following Xuan's pace.
Jake: 哦对
Jake: Oh right.
Jake: 殊途同归
Jake: Different paths, same destination.
Katrina:  柯达照相
Katrina: Kodak photos.
Alice:没关系
Alice: It's okay.
Tasha: 一下跑了好远坐着
Tasha: Ran so far in one go and sat down.
Alice:没事
Alice: It's fine.
Tasha: 伤心
Tasha: Heartbroken.
Alice:买一套工具自己做
Alice: Buy a set of tools and do it yourself.
Tasha: 早知道不翻了
Tasha: Shouldn't have flipped it.
Alice: 这翻掉了
Alice: It's flipped off.
Katrina:  那你有冲洗出来吗还是直打
Katrina: Did you get it developed or just printed?
Alice:看啥呢
Alice: What are you looking at?
Tasha: 看你的小猫眼
Tasha: Looking at your cat's eye.
Alice: 哈哈哈小猫眼
Alice: Hahaha cat's eye.
Alice: 笑死了
Alice: So funny.
Tasha: 是吧
Tasha: Right?
Alice: 啊什么是小猫眼
Alice: Ah what's a cat's eye?
Tasha: 试送了一个专业
Tasha: Trying to be professional.
Alice: 我不知道哎
Alice: I don't know.
Alice: 啥是小猫眼
Alice: What's a cat's eye?
Tasha: 就是眼睛像猫的那种眼睛一样
Tasha: It's like those eyes that look like a cat's eyes.
Tasha: 很翘
Tasha: Very perky.
Tasha: 然后有几根是那样很
Tasha: And a few of them are like that very...
Alice:很长的
Alice: It's really long.
Alice: 感觉这个是通向天堂的
Alice: Feels like this leads to heaven.
Alice: 找到一双长睫毛的大眼睛哎
Alice: Found a pair of big eyes with long eyelashes.
Alice: 找到了在那
Alice: Found it over there.
Alice: 哎让ai来一下
Alice: Hey, let AI handle this.
Lucia: 不好意思又踩到你了
Lucia: Sorry, I stepped on you again.
Shure:  哎呦sorry sorry
Shure: Oh, sorry, sorry.
Katrina:  海澜之家
Katrina: HLA.
Katrina:  海澜之家就在我们家旁边
Katrina: HLA is right next to our house.
Tasha: 在甜甜圈中找到一块饼干
Tasha: Found a cookie inside the donut.
Lucia: 甜甜圈中找到一块饼干
Lucia: Found a cookie inside the donut.
Alice:哦在哪
Alice: Oh, where?
Shure: 海澜之家男人的衣柜
Shure: HLA, men's wardrobe.
Jake: 这得多瞎啊
Jake: How blind can you be?
Jake: 他看不到啊
Jake: He can't see it.
Alice: 还有呢
Alice: What else?
Alice: 贼不有股有毒的味道
Tasha: 用这个眼镜去测试你看
Tasha: Use these glasses to test, look.
Tasha: 做测试这
Tasha: Do the test here.
Lucia: 感觉刚装修完似得
Lucia: Feels like it was just renovated.
Tasha: 在车站中找到海澜之家
Tasha: Found HLA at the station.
Alice: 哦原来在这等着我们呢
Alice: Oh, it's waiting for us here.
Alice: 软广
Alice: Product placement.
Tasha: 还真没找着
Tasha: Still can't find it.
Shure: 真的在用心的找诶
Shure: Really trying hard to find it.
Jake: 怎么找啊
Jake: How to find it?
Jake: 海澜之家是啥啊
Jake: What's HLA?
Alice:海澜之家
Alice: HLA.
Lucia: 就是一个卖男装的品牌
Lucia: It's a men's clothing brand.
Jake:那他是什么
Jake: So what is it?
Jake: 找他的logo吗
Jake: Looking for its logo?
Jake: 他logo是什么样的
Jake: What does its logo look like?
Alice: 有嘛区别呢
Alice: Does it make a difference?
Alice:让AI来找一下
Alice: Let AI find it.
Jake:都不知道要找什么
Jake: Don't even know what to look for.
Tasha: 难度可能是进阶的
Tasha: The difficulty might be advanced.
Alice: 他可能就是
Alice: He might just be...
Jake:他应该
Jake: He should...
Alice: 为了给你留下一个深刻的印象
Alice: Trying to make a lasting impression.
Jake:可能他就没有
Jake: Maybe he just didn't...
Tasha: 然后就一直在找海澜
Tasha: Then we kept looking for HLA.
Jake:对一个一个找
Jake: Yeah, one by one.
Alice: 然后你就特别特别想知道
Alice: And you really, really wanted to know...
Alice: 海澜之家到底长啥样
Alice: What HLA really looks like.
Alice: 然后他的目的就达到了
Alice: So his goal was achieved.
Alice:是这样吗
Alice: Is that right?
Jake: 所以应该长啥样
Jake: So what should it look like?
Alice: 我也不知道
Alice: I don't know either.
Jake: 海澜之家是自己有个logo是长这样吗
Jake: Does HLA have its own logo that looks like this?
Jake: 还是啥呀
Jake: Or what?
Alice: 海澜之家
Alice: HLA.
Alice: 我就记得一个h一个l他们家的门面
Alice: I just remember an H and an L on their storefront.
Jake:他logo长啥样不知道哇
Jake: Do we know what their logo looks like?
Alice:什么
Alice: What?
Lucia: 不了解因为因为咱们平常也不买男装
Lucia: No idea, because we usually don't buy men's clothes.
Alice: 我觉得里面就是没有我感觉都一样
Alice: I feel like inside, they all look the same.
Jake: 对我也不买男装
Jake: Yeah, I don't buy men's clothes either.
Tasha: 那他穿什么
Tasha: So what does he wear?
Alice:怪怪的
Alice: Weird.
Jake: 就这个哈哈哈哈
Jake: Just this, hahaha.
Lucia: 女装
Lucia: Women's clothes.
Lucia: 淘宝T恤啊你穿
Lucia: Taobao T-shirts, right?
Tasha: 你看喜茶标志很明显
Tasha: Look, Heytea's logo is very obvious.
Alice:对
Alice: Yeah.
Jake: 这个确实哎
Jake: That's true.
Lucia: 那可能是上面确实有个标志只是没找到
Lucia: Maybe there's a logo, we just didn't find it.
Tasha: 还测吗哈哈
Tasha: Are we still testing, haha?
Alice: 这有一股有毒的味道
Alice: There's a toxic smell here.
Alice: 感觉在这闻久了要晕倒
Alice: Feels like staying here too long will make you faint.
Lucia: +1
Lucia:有种没装修完的
Lucia: Feels like it's not fully renovated.
Tasha: 是两位男生推购物车吗
Tasha: Are the two guys pushing shopping carts?
Jake:行啊
Jake: Sure.
Tasha: 推两辆是吗
Tasha: Pushing two, right?
Jake: 行啊没问题
Jake: Sure, no problem.
Tasha: 一一边采购酒一边采购食材是吗
Tasha: One for buying alcohol, one for buying groceries, right?
Jake: 呃啊酒要单独一个车吧
Jake: Uh, alcohol probably needs its own cart.
Lucia: 哎那还有小的
Lucia: Hey, there's a small one.
Jake: 推个小的
Jake: Push a small one.
Lucia: 还有小的
Lucia: There's a small one.
Lucia: 啊太小了推起来不好推
Lucia: Ah, it's too small, it's hard to push.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Tasha: 有那个小把手
Tasha: There's that little handle.
Alice: 就是小孩推的意思吗
Alice: You mean it's for kids to push?
Jake: 哦是
Jake: Oh, yes.
Lucia: 是把小孩放在里面推小孩的意思吗
Lucia: Do you mean putting the kid inside and pushing the kid?
Tasha: 是让小孩推这个车的意思
Tasha: No, it's for kids to push this cart.
Alice:是让小孩推得
Alice: It's for kids to push.
Jake: 小孩应该也进不去
Jake: Kids probably can't fit in.
Jake: 这得是
Jake: This must be...
Lucia: 不会是把小孩放在里面
Lucia: No way it's for putting kids inside.
Jake:猫
Tasha: 这这小孩
Tasha: This, this kid...
Alice:坐这
Alice: Sit here.
Jake: 请
Jake: Please.
Tasha: 谁
Tasha: Who?
Alice:请
Alice: Please.
Tasha: 谁
Tasha: Who?
Jake: 都行啊
Jake: Anyone is fine.
Shure:  我能上吗
Shure: Can I get on?
Jake: 来
Jake: Come.
Shure: 算了
Shure: Nevermind.
Jake: 给你推货
Jake: I'll push you.
Jake: 给你推冰柜去
Jake: I'll push you to the freezer.
Jake: 就那个水产
Jake: To the seafood section.
Tasha: 西瓜
Tasha: Watermelons.
Alice:西瓜
Alice: Watermelons.
Tasha: 买二得三
Tasha: Buy two, get three.
Alice: 榴莲怎么这么便宜
Alice: Why is durian so cheap?
Alice: 是不是该下了
Alice: Is it about to go bad?
Tasha: 有人不爱吃榴莲吗
Tasha: Does anyone not like durian?
Jake: 我可以吃
Jake: I can eat it.
Alice:没有吧
Alice: No way.
Lucia: 不是很爱
Lucia: Not a big fan.
Shure:  怎么说咱们是分头行动
Shure: So, we're splitting up, right?
Lucia: 但没事你想吃的话
Lucia: But it's okay, if you want to eat it.
Shure:  你把那个图po到那里吧
Shure: You can post that picture there.
Jake: 我们有分工吗
Jake: Do we have assignments?
Katrina: 发群里吗
Katrina: Post it in the group?
Jake: 我们分几个路啊
Jake: How many routes are we splitting into?
Tasha: 分几个路啊
Tasha: 不知道呀
Tasha: No idea.
Jake: 其实我们戴着这个眼镜
Jake: Actually, with these glasses on...
Jake: 绕着一圈就重建了
Jake: ...we can just walk around once and rebuild it.
Jake: 就是这个整个商场商场就3D重建了
Jake: The entire mall will be reconstructed in 3D.
Tasha: 场景
Tasha: The scene.
Shure: 所以那天
Shure: So that day...
Jake: 就一个赛博盒马
Jake: ...just like a cyber Hema.
Shure:  让我哈哈哈
Shure: ...made me laugh so hard.
Tasha: 没有网哎 你记得吗
Tasha: There was no internet, do you remember?
Jake: 每个角落走一圈
Jake: Walk around every corner.
Katrina: 我发了
Katrina: I posted it.
Shure:  会怎么样
Shure: What would happen?
Katrina: 那就分
Katrina: Then split up.
Katrina:  分其实5-10就是你们买菜啊
Katrina: Splitting into groups of 5-10 for buying groceries and daily necessities.
Katrina:  生活用品的那种地方
Katrina: You can split into two groups.
Katrina:  可以你们那就分两拨
Katrina: Split into 5-11.
Tasha: 那就5-11呗
Tasha: Then it'll be 5-11.
Jake: 分两拨分两拨
Jake: Split into two groups, two groups.
Katrina: 分两拨
Katrina: Split into two groups.
Tasha:  5-11
Tasha: 5-11.
Katrina:  5-11跟1-4
Katrina: 5-11 and 1-4.
Tasha: 你是1-4和12对吗
Tasha: You're 1-4 and 12, right?
Katrina:  啊可以可以
Katrina: Yeah, that's fine.
Lucia: 行
Lucia: Okay.
Katrina:  1-4和12
Katrina: 1-4 and 12.
Katrina:  走我俩去哪个
Katrina: Let's go, which one are we going to?
Jake: 这是什么
Jake: What's this?
Jake: 这是这是什么组
Jake: What's this group?
Jake: 这是什么组
Tasha: 这是食材组
Tasha: This is the food group.
Katrina: 我我去
Katrina: I'll go.
Katrina:  我们俩去买酒吧
Katrina: We are going to buy alcohol.
Tasha: 这是酒组
Tasha: This is the alcohol group.
Jake: 酒组行行好
Jake: The alcohol group, okay.
Katrina:  那你们还要一个过来不
Katrina: So do you want another one?
Katrina:  12123456 我俩再加一个
Katrina: 12123456, let's add one more.
Lucia: 33好了那就
Lucia: Alright, 33 then.
Katrina:  33
Katrina: 33.
Lucia: 行
Lucia: Okay.
Katrina: 他肯定要
Katrina: He definitely wants it.
Jake: 行那怎么说
Jake: Alright, how do we say it?
Jake:对食材
Jake: About the ingredients.
Katrina:  他是你们的主主星
Katrina: He's your main star.
Katrina:  组合里你俩选
Katrina: You two choose in the group.
Lucia: 哦对
Lucia: Oh, right.
Alice: 我我我跟他绑定
Alice: Me, me, me, I'll pair with him.
Lucia: 我都都行
Lucia: I'm okay with anything.
Lucia: 那我来好了
Lucia: Then I'll do it.
Tasha: 嘿嘿嘿嘿好
Tasha: Hehehe, alright.
Katrina:  好反正你还比较懂调酒
Katrina: Okay, you actually know more about mixing drinks.
Alice:走
Alice: Let's go.
Tasha: 对你们三个都是懂酒的
Tasha: Yeah, the three of you know drinks well.
Lucia: 也没有那么
Lucia: Not that much.
Alice:走
Alice: Let's go.
Lucia: 我我我没有那么懂了其实
Lucia: I don't know that much, actually.
Jake: 确实我是一点都不懂
Jake: Honestly, I don't know anything about it.
Jake: 我咖啡都不喝
Jake: I don't even drink coffee.
Jake: 都没法买啥也没法
Jake: Can't buy anything, don't know how.
Jake: 但是好像食品
Jake: But it seems like food...
Jake: 我也不懂
Jake: I don't know either.
Lucia: 我可以申请买个水果
Lucia: Can I apply to buy some fruit?
Tasha: 买
Tasha: Sure.
Tasha: 想吃什么你可以跟我说啊
Tasha: If you want anything, just tell me.
Lucia: 随便只要是个水果就行
Lucia: Anything, as long as it's fruit.
Katrina:  我想要那个青提
Katrina: I want those green grapes.
Jake:你也可以
Jake: You can too.
Katrina:  我要那个青提
Katrina: I want those green grapes.
Katrina:  阳光玫瑰那种
Katrina: The Sunshine Rose kind.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Lucia: 好那我那我也吃这个就可以了
Lucia: Alright, I'll have those too then.
Tasha: 啊好
Tasha: Ah, okay.
Tasha: 啊这个会买的
Tasha: Yeah, we'll get those.
Tasha: 您觉得买一盒还是买两盒呢
Tasha: Do you think we should buy one box or two?
Jake: 买买哎我看看啊
Jake: Buy, buy, let me see.
Tasha: 我觉得可以买两盒
Tasha: I think we can buy two boxes.
Tasha: 一盒做蛋糕一盒也吃
Tasha: One for making cakes and the other for eating.
Jake:行
Jake: Sure.
Katrina:  是的
Katrina: Yes.
Alice:这个长得不好换一个
Alice: This one doesn't look good, let's change it.
Jake: 是不是买两盒
Jake: Are we buying two boxes?
Jake: 两盒都吃了呀
Jake: We ate both boxes.
Alice:这个吧
Alice: This one.
Alice: 这个大
Alice: This one's big.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Jake: 你们可以商量商量
Jake: You guys can discuss it.
Jake: 为什么选这个
Jake: Why choose this one?
Tasha: 这个草莓好吃
Tasha: This strawberry tastes good.
Jake: 不是就是为什么这个
Jake: No, why this one?
Alice: 因为这个有白的感觉没有很
Alice: Because this one has a white part, it doesn't seem very...
Tasha: 他这个要买
Tasha: We need to buy this one.
Alice:饱满成熟
Alice: Plump and ripe.
Tasha: 你看他这个虽然小但他多
Tasha: See, this one is small but there are many.
Tasha: 这个虽然大但他少
Tasha: This one is big but there are fewer.
Alice: 他多吗
Alice: Are there many?
Tasha: 对对这个是多两排这个是少两排的
Tasha: Yeah, this one has two more rows, this one has two fewer rows.
Tasha: 我经常吃
Tasha: I eat this often.
Tasha: 对，他少两排
Tasha: Yeah, it has two fewer rows.
Alice:啊没发现
Alice: Ah, I didn't notice.
Tasha: 他少两排
Tasha: It has two fewer rows.
Tasha: 你看你没事
Tasha: Look, you don't mind.
Alice:诶一排还是两排啊
Alice: Eh, is it one row or two rows?
Jake: 他这个他这个挡着
Jake: This one, this one blocks it.
Jake: 是有还是没有啊
Jake: Does it have or not?
Tasha: 呃有
Tasha: Uh, it has.
Alice: 哦这是5排这是6排
Alice: Oh, this has 5 rows, this has 6 rows.
Tasha: 呃就是一排两排
Tasha: Uh, it's one row, two rows.
Jake:哦没那么狗是吧
Jake: Oh, it's not that stingy, right?
Tasha: 这是一排两排三排四排对对
Tasha: This is one row, two rows, three rows, four rows, right.
Alice: 哦嗯那么要大的还是要小的呢
Alice: Oh, hmm, so should we get the big one or the small one?
Tasha: 那肯定要大的
Tasha: Definitely the big one.
Alice:大的吧
Alice: The big one then.
Tasha: 这就是他们刚刚点名的
Tasha: This is the one they just mentioned.
Alice: 阳光玫瑰
Alice: Sunshine Rose.
Alice: 找一个果形饱满的
Alice: Find a plump one.
Tasha: 我觉得这个比较多
Tasha: I think this one has more.
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Alice: 都500克吧
Alice: They're all 500 grams, right?
Tasha: 但好像都是500克
Tasha: But it seems like they're all 500 grams.
Tasha: 那我选他吧
Tasha: Then I'll choose this one.
Tasha: 你觉得呢
Tasha: What do you think?
Tasha: 你有没有心仪的
Tasha: Do you have a favorite?
Alice: 我觉得长得都差不多
Alice: I think they all look similar.
Tasha: 那这个吧
Tasha: Then this one.
Alice:就这样吧
Alice: Let's go with this.
Alice: 他们家品控还可以
Jake: 我看看这都多少钱
Jake: Let me see how much these cost.
Tasha: 不能吃现切的
Tasha: We can't eat the freshly cut ones.
Jake: 我看看都多少钱
Jake: Let me see the prices.
Jake: 我就看一眼
Jake: I'll just take a look.
Jake: 多少钱我比比价
Jake: I'll compare the prices.
Jake: 为什么不能吃现切的
Jake: Why can't we eat the freshly cut ones?
Tasha: 因为你没听过前段时间现切的事吗
Tasha: Haven't you heard about the freshly cut ones lately?
Tasha: 把坏的切掉把好的然后
Tasha: They cut off the bad parts and sell the good ones.
Jake: 好的就在这卖了
Jake: They sell the good ones here.
Jake: 坏的就在这卖了
Jake: And sell the bad ones here.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Right.
Jake: 给世界人民涨涨知识
Jake: Let's educate the people of the world.
Tasha: 还有什么让我们看一看
Tasha: What else do we have to look at?
Tasha: 水果采购
Tasha: Fruit shopping.
Tasha: 蓝莓要吗
Tasha: Do we need blueberries?
Alice: 蓝莓在门口那个大果
Alice: The big ones are near the entrance.
Alice: 需要凤梨吗
Alice: Do we need pineapple?
Tasha: 你喜欢吃可以拿一盒
Tasha: If you like it, you can get a box.
Alice:我觉得一般
Alice: I think it's just okay.
Tasha: 我也觉得一般
Tasha: I think so too.
Alice:有没有买了几种啊
Alice: Did we buy several kinds?
Alice: 这个是用来吃的
Alice: This one is for eating.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Right.
Alice: 这个是用来摆的
Alice: This one is for display.
Tasha: 这个也可以用来摆
Tasha: This one can also be for display.
Alice: 再加一个黄的
Alice: Add a yellow one.
Tasha: 黄的芒果
Tasha: Yellow mango.
Alice:芒果
Alice: Mango.
Jake:菠萝
Jake: Pineapple.
Alice: 芒果
Alice: Mango
Katrina: get
Katrina: Got it
Tasha: 菠萝不太好放在甜品里
Tasha: Pineapple isn't really good in desserts.
Alice:凤梨
Alice: Pineapple
Jake: 甜品来尝尝
Jake: Try the dessert
Alice: 买这个吧
Alice: Let's buy this one
Alice:这个他们家的
Alice: This one from their place
Alice:那种
Alice: That kind
Tasha: 可以呀
Alice: 那种叫什么来着
Alice: What was that kind called again?
Jake: 不是不能现切吗
Jake: Can't they cut it fresh?
Katrina:  还要买可乐
Katrina: We also need to buy cola
Jake: 到底能不能现切
Jake: Can they cut it fresh or not?
Tasha: 其实我觉得现切的不太好
Tasha: I actually think fresh cut isn't that good
Tasha: 你可以买那个让他帮你现场切
Tasha: You can buy it and ask them to cut it on the spot
Jake: 那可以啊
Jake: That works
Jake: 但是买凤梨不是不是
Jake: But buying pineapple isn't, isn't it
Jake:放不放甜点里
Jake: Should we put it in the dessert?
Tasha: 不放
Tasha: No
Jake: 啊就自己吃
Jake: Ah, just eat it ourselves
Alice: 拿一个吧
Alice: Take one
Jake:好让他切吧
Alice:哎呦
Alice: Oh no
Jake: 给他拍一个特写一个切的
Jake: Take a close-up shot of them cutting it
Jake: 可乐
Jake: Cola
Tasha: 你看他可以呼叫店员帮你切
Tasha: You can ask the staff to cut it for you
Jake: 好切
Jake: Okay, cut it
Tasha: 挑的话挑那种刺比较尖的
Tasha: If you choose, pick the one with sharper spines
Jake: 挑比较大格子比较大
Jake: Choose the one with bigger grids
Jake: 这个我会
Jake: I know this
Jake: 这个我在新加坡
Jake: I did this in Singapore
Tasha: 真的吗 好
Tasha: Really? Okay
Alice:这个不错吧
Alice: This one looks good, right?
Jake: 这个我在新加坡切过
Jake: I cut this in Singapore
Tasha: 你觉得这两个哪个好
Tasha: Which one do you think is better?
Jake:这个我看看
Jake: Let me see
Alice:还有点扎呢
Alice: It's still a bit prickly
Alice:这个是不是更熟
Alice: Is this one riper?
Jake:这个吧
Jake: This one then
Alice:我也不知道
Alice: I don't know either
Alice: 绿不拉几差不多吧
Alice: This kind of green is okay, right?
Alice: 差不多这个吧
Alice: Almost like this, right?
Jake: 看谁胖一点哇
Jake: Let's see who is a bit chubbier.
Alice:这个
Jake:这个吧就这个吧
Jake: This one, let's go with this one.
Alice:就这个吧
Alice: Let's go with this one.
Alice: 您好
Alice: Hello.
Jake: 您好
Jake: Hello.
Jake: 切，谢谢您
Jake: Cut it, thank you.
Jake: 这就下班了
Jake: Done for the day.
Alice:下班了
Alice: Done for the day.
Jake: 这才几点
Jake: What time is it?
Jake: 那我们现在自己
Jake: So now we...
Jake:我们看中这个了
Jake: We like this one.
Tasha: 那他什么时候开始切
Tasha: When will he start cutting?
Tasha: 行吧那我们买个这个吧
Tasha: Alright, let's buy this one.
Alice:那我们买这种吧拿一个
Alice: Let's buy this one, grab one.
Tasha: 你挑一个
Tasha: You pick one.
Jake: 行吧那就至于大家信他一个吧
Jake: Alright, let's trust him on this.
Alice:这个吧
Alice: This one.
Tasha: 你挑挑哪个
Tasha: Pick one.
Tasha: 是6个的啊
Tasha: It's a pack of six, right?
Tasha: 我刚看到这个是6个但他这有霉点
Tasha: I just saw this pack of six, but it has some mold spots.
Alice:芒够
Alice: Not enough.
Tasha: 所以要挑一个
Tasha: So we need to pick another one.
Tasha: 另一个6个的
Tasha: Another pack of six.
Alice:小台芒的吗
Alice: Small mangoes?
Tasha: 发挥你的眼睛对
Tasha: Use your eyes, yes.
Alice: 小台芒比较甜比较软
Alice: Small mangoes are sweeter and softer.
Tasha: 对小台芒
Tasha: Yes, small mangoes.
Tasha: 走吧
Tasha: Let's go.
Alice:各留吧
Alice: Let's go.
Alice:走
Tasha: OK看看水果就买齐了吧
Tasha: Okay, we should have all the fruits now.
Tasha: 下一步是
Tasha: Next is...
Tasha: 牛奶无菌蛋牛奶
Tasha: Milk, pasteurized eggs, milk.
Alice:这是你外送的
Alice: Is this your delivery?
Jake: 对我在拍他
Jake: Yes, I'm recording it.
Jake: 给个特写
Jake: Give it a close-up.
Alice:这款还挺好喝的
Alice: This one is pretty good.
Tasha: 我我也觉着
Tasha: I think so too.
Tasha: 椰子水拿一瓶吧
Tasha: Grab a bottle of coconut water.
Tasha: 但在哪呢
Tasha: But where is it?
Alice:椰子水买那个吧
Alice: Buy that coconut water.
Tasha: 这个哎
Tasha: This one.
Alice:买那个
Alice: Buy that one.
Tasha: 这个贵了一点
Tasha: This one's a bit expensive.
Tasha: 买这个
Tasha: Buy this one.
Alice: 啊不是这个就是那个便宜的
Alice: Ah, no, this is the cheaper one.
Tasha: 这个是便
Tasha: This one's chea-
Tasha: 是便宜的啊
Tasha: It's the cheaper one.
Tasha: 他们都是一升
Tasha: They're all one liter.
Alice: 这怎么是8块9了
Alice: How is this 8.9?
Tasha: 对他们都是一升
Tasha: Yes, they're all one liter.
Tasha: 但他只要8块9
Tasha: But this one is only 8.9.
Tasha: 他还更贵
Tasha: This one's even more expensive.
Alice: 果汁哦
Alice: Juice, oh.
Alice: 果汁是他们买
Alice: They're buying the juice.
Tasha: 还有东西吗
Tasha: Anything else?
Tasha: 牛奶无菌蛋
Tasha: Milk and pasteurized eggs.
Alice: 牛奶买了吗
Alice: Did we get milk?
Tasha: 牛奶买了
Tasha: Got the milk.
Alice: 两盒够不够
Alice: Are two cartons enough?
Tasha: 够了吧
Tasha: Should be enough.
Alice:无菌蛋
Alice: Pasteurized eggs.
Tasha: 鸡蛋鸡蛋
Tasha: Eggs, eggs.
Jake:淡奶油在什么地方
Jake: Where's the whipping cream?
Tasha: 淡奶油在
Tasha: The whipping cream is...
Jake:在很里边吗
Jake: Is it deep inside?
Alice: 奶油应该在酸奶这边
Alice: Cream should be near the yogurt.
Alice: 是差不多的地吧
Alice: Around the same area.
Tasha: 我觉得差不多在冰柜这里
Tasha: I think it's around the freezer section.
Jake: 要不问问他嘞
Jake: How about we ask him?
Alice: 安佳的吗
Alice: The Anchor brand?
Tasha: 是的但他比网上还贵
Tasha: Yes, but it's more expensive than online.
Tasha: 他没有嗯
Tasha: They don't have, um...
Jake: 我来瞅瞅你们买的啥
Jake: Let me see what you bought.
Jake: 你们看起来进度一般了
Jake: You guys seem to be making average progress.
Katrina:  嗯没找到饮料
Katrina: Hmm, couldn't find the drinks.
Shure:  是要我们大买特买那个意思吗
Shure: Are we supposed to buy a lot?
Lucia: 他买了椰子水
Lucia: He bought coconut water.
Lucia: 刚好我们不用买了啊
Lucia: Great, now we don't need to buy it.
Katrina:  哦他们买了椰子水
Katrina: Oh, they bought coconut water.
Katrina:  是要用椰奶还是椰子水啊
Katrina: Should we use coconut milk or coconut water?
Lucia: 呃其实最好是椰奶
Lucia: Um, actually, coconut milk is better.
Lucia: 但是咱们也没有那么那个啥嘛
Lucia: But we don't have that much of it.
Shure:  椰奶和椰子水完全两个味啊
Shure: Coconut milk and coconut water taste completely different.
Katrina: 对
Katrina: True.
Tasha: 我暂时还不在你
Tasha: I'm not with you at the moment.
Tasha: 要不明天再
Tasha: How about tomorrow?
Tasha: 我明天再去拿行吗
Tasha: Can I pick it up tomorrow?
Tasha: 好谢谢
Tasha: Okay, thanks.
Alice: 选好了吗
Alice: Have you decided?
Tasha: 好吧价格差不多呢
Tasha: Well, the price is almost the same.
Alice: 买两个
Alice: Buy two.
Tasha: 你看网上才卖12块五
Tasha: Look, it's only 12.5 yuan online.
Alice: 是这家的吗
Alice: Is it from this store?
Tasha: 是这个
Tasha: Yes, this one.
Jake:奶油找着了吗
Jake: Did you find the cream?
Alice: 但是它的包装不一样
Alice: But the packaging is different.
Tasha: 好吧它是安佳
Tasha: Okay, it's Anchor.
Jake:就这个
Jake: This is it.
Tasha: 它是雀巢
Tasha: It's Nestlé.
Alice: 安佳会比较贵本来就比他贵
Alice: Anchor is more expensive, it's always been pricier.
Tasha: 贵了10块钱一瓶
Tasha: It's 10 yuan more per bottle.
Alice:是
Alice: Yes.
Tasha: 如果说这一瓶可以做6个纸杯蛋糕的话
Tasha: If one bottle makes 6 cupcakes...
Alice: 我们得做多少个
Alice: How many do we need to make?
Tasha: 6个太贵了
Tasha: Six is too expensive.
Tasha: 这120块钱我觉得就要大差大要
Tasha: I think 120 yuan is a bit too much.
Tasha: 买先买4瓶吧
Tasha: Let's buy 4 bottles first.
Alice: 或者现在在网上买还来的及吗
Alice: Or can we still order online and get it in time?
Tasha: 也可以吧
Tasha: Maybe.
Tasha: 蓝风车
Tasha: Blue Windmill.
Jake: 这还能小时达吗还是明天达
Jake: Can we get it delivered within an hour, or is it for tomorrow?
Tasha: 是啊我要看看嘛
Tasha: Yeah, I need to check.
Jake:你这可以选的诶
Jake: You can choose this one.
Tasha: 一件
Tasha: One piece.
Tasha: 你看他这个小时达的哎
Tasha: Look, this one can be delivered within an hour.
Tasha: 五棵松店呀
Tasha: From the Wukesong store.
Tasha: 就这个
Tasha: This one.
Alice: 你知道五颗松在哪吗
Alice: Do you know where Wukesong is?
Tasha: 不知道呵呵
Tasha: No idea, haha.
Tasha: 我选的地址可能在那哦
Tasha: The address I chose might be there though.
Alice: 五科松在
Alice: Wukesong is...
Tasha: 在我学校呢
Tasha: It's near my school.
Alice: 在另一边
Alice: On the other side.
Jake: 我帮你拿
Jake: Let me help you with that.
Alice:奶盖
Alice: Milk cap.
Tasha: 谢谢你
Tasha: Thank you.
Jake: 不用谢
Jake: You're welcome.
Alice: 这好可爱这是什么
Alice: This is so cute, what is it?
Tasha: 如果少了可能还要再买
Tasha: If there's not enough, we might need to buy more.
Jake: 那就网上买
Jake: Then just buy it online.
Jake: 不要紧啊
Jake: It's no big deal.
Alice: 对
Alice: Yeah.
Jake:然后下单
Jake: Then place the order.
Tasha: 如果22号的那天的话可以先在网上买
Tasha: If it's on the 22nd, we can buy it online first.
Jake:22号那一天
Jake: On the 22nd.
Tasha: 不是说那天要做蛋糕吗
Tasha: Didn't we say we were going to make a cake that day?
Alice:还早嘛
Alice: It's still early.
Jake: 这戴个帽子就把头发挡住了
Jake: Just wear a hat to cover your hair.
Tasha: 然后要什么来着
Tasha: And what else do we need?
Tasha: 鸡蛋
Tasha: Eggs.
Alice: 对无菌蛋
Alice: Yes, sterile eggs.
Tasha: 鸡蛋
Tasha: Eggs.
Tasha: 糖盐
Tasha: Sugar, salt.
Tasha: 奶粉咖啡冻奶油薄荷保鲜膜
Tasha: Milk powder, coffee, whipped cream, mint, cling film.
Tasha: 蛋挞皮草莓
Tasha: Tart shells, strawberries.
Tasha: 美文纸为什么也是我们买
Tasha: Why do we have to buy the fancy paper too?
Tasha: 金针菇3-4个
Tasha: Enoki mushrooms, 3-4 pieces.
Tasha: 松花蛋娃娃菜
Tasha: Century eggs, baby bok choy.
Shure:  元气森林吗
Shure: Genki Forest drink?
Tasha: 记住了吗
Tasha: Got it?
Tasha: 走吧
Tasha: Let's go.
Jake: 娃娃菜走
Jake: Baby bok choy, let's go.
Jake: 哈哈你哈哈哈哈
Jake: Haha, you... hahaha.
Tasha: 诶鸡蛋
Tasha: Oh, eggs.
Alice:无菌蛋吗
Alice: Sterile eggs?
Tasha: 买鸡蛋送松花蛋
Tasha: Buy eggs and get century eggs for free.
Tasha: 刚好哎
Tasha: How convenient!
Jake: 诶刚好啊
Jake: Hey, that's perfect.
Tasha: 是无菌的吗
Tasha: Is it sterile?
Alice: 鲜鸡蛋吧这是
Alice: These are fresh eggs.
Tasha: 啊鲜鸡蛋也可以吧
Tasha: Ah, fresh eggs are fine too.
Jake: 你们家离高邮远吗
Jake: Is your house far from Gaoyou?
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Jake: 高邮
Jake: Gaoyou.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Jake: 啊你们家离那远
Jake: Is your house far from there?
Alice: 高邮鸭蛋哦
Alice: Gaoyou salted duck eggs.
Alice: 咸鸭蛋
Alice: Salted duck eggs.
Tasha: 不远
Tasha: Not far.
Jake:不远
Jake: Not far.
Tasha: 你们家也不远啊
Tasha: Your house isn't far either.
Jake:啊对确实
Jake: Ah, right, indeed.
Alice:这两个都是鲜
Alice: Both of these are fresh.
Alice: 哦那个是可生食的哦
Alice: Oh, that one is safe to eat raw.
Tasha: 这呢我觉得可生食的买一点就行了
Tasha: For this, I think just buying a bit of the edible raw ones is fine.
Tasha: 然后再买一盒这个也可以了
Tasha: And then buying a box of these is okay too.
Alice: 行啊
Alice: Sure.
Tasha: 这个就买
Tasha: Let's buy this.
Tasha: 呃做那个提拉米苏
Tasha: Uh, for making tiramisu.
Alice:提拉米苏用
Alice: For tiramisu?
Tasha: 对然后别的都可以用
Tasha: Yes, and the rest can use
Alice:‘用 呃
Alice: Using, uh
Tasha: 用非无菌的蛋
Tasha: non-sterile eggs.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Alice: 熟的就行
Alice: Cooked ones are fine.
Jake: 无菌蛋无菌蛋是什么意思
Jake: What does sterile egg mean?
Tasha: 无菌蛋就是你现在直接可以吃下去
Tasha: Sterile egg means you can eat it right away.
Jake: 就是他为什么叫无菌蛋
Jake: Why is it called a sterile egg?
Tasha: 因为有
Tasha: Because it has
Tasha: 因为他就是不会有细菌吧
Tasha: no bacteria, I guess.
Tasha: 可能
Tasha: Maybe.
Alice:是什么沙门氏菌什么的
Alice: Like no salmonella or something.
Shure: 哪有苏打水
Shure: Where's the soda water?
Jake: 他就是这个鸡比较牛逼
Jake: Is it because the chicken is amazing?
Jake: 还是
Jake: Or
Alice: 就是他的那个饲养流程比较那啥
Alice: It's because the breeding process is strict.
Alice: 控制比较严
Alice: They control it strictly.
Jake: 刚生下来然后就被保存起来了之类的
Jake: It was just born and then preserved or something like that.
Alice: 具体的不是很清楚
Alice: I don't know the specifics.
Jake: OK OK行
Jake: OK, OK, sure.
Tasha: 无菌蛋牛奶白糖盐
Tasha: Sterilized eggs, milk, white sugar, salt.
Alice: 调味料那边
Alice: Over there with the seasonings.
Alice: 哦那边是蔬菜
Alice: Oh, the vegetables are over there.
Alice: 买点菌菇类的
Alice: Let's get some mushrooms.
Alice: 黄瓜花也能吃吗
Alice: Can you eat cucumber flowers?
Alice: 为什么娃娃菜这么贵
Alice: Why is napa cabbage so expensive?
Jake:高山鲜
Jake: It's fresh from the high mountains.
Alice: 没有普通的吗
Alice: Don't they have regular ones?
Jake:没有
Jake: No, they don't.
Alice: 找找别的啊
Alice: Let's look for something else.
Tasha: 老板你有想吃的吗
Tasha: Boss, do you have anything you want to eat?
Alice: 这是大白菜啊
Alice: This is just regular cabbage.
Jake:我把我想吃的人都招过来了 会做吗
Jake: I invited all the people I want to eat with. Can you cook?
Tasha: 就买这个娃娃菜买了吗
Tasha: Should we buy this napa cabbage?
Jake:会做好吃的菜的人都招过来了
Jake: I invited people who can cook delicious food.
Alice: 没有但是我感觉好贵啊它
Tasha: 但是看着也挺好嫩的怎么这么贵去我家地里摘吧
Tasha: But it looks so tender. Why is it so expensive? Let's go pick some from my garden.
Alice: 主要是他一煮他就很小啦
Alice: The main thing is it gets really small when you cook it.
Alice: 看看
Tasha: 那拿点上海青
Tasha: Then let's get some bok choy.
Tasha: 上海青才一块钱哈哈
Tasha: Bok choy is only one yuan, haha.
Alice:但是
Alice: But...
Alice: 但是他没那个味
Alice: But it doesn't have that flavor.
Alice:甜的
Alice: It's sweet.
Alice: 让我找一下
Alice: Let me find it.
Alice: 要不然买成这个
Alice: Or else we can buy this.
Alice: 我们我们可以我们把帮
Alice: We, we can, we can help.
Tasha: 也可以
Tasha: That works too.
Alice:我
Alice: I...
Jake: 为什么这个不行
Jake: Why can't we use this one?
Alice: 因为那个比较贵
Alice: Because that one is more expensive.
Alice:哼哼哼哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hmm hmm hmm, hahaha.
Alice: 要不然我们
Alice: Or we can...
Jake:他为什么贵啊
Jake: Why is it so expensive?
Jake: 这个多少钱
Jake: How much is this?
Alice:他是 白菜能贵到哪
Alice: How expensive can cabbage be?
Alice: 一千 1千克的话
Alice: One kilogram is...
Alice:白菜
Alice: Cabbage...
Alice:姜
Alice: Ginger.
Tasha: 没有价格怎么回事
Tasha: Why isn't there a price?
Alice:怎么搞的
Alice: What's going on?
Alice:这是杭白菜吗
Alice: Is this Hangzhou cabbage?
Tasha: 你去那扫个码就知道了
Tasha: Just scan the code over there and you'll know.
Alice:这没没称
Alice: There's no scale here.
Alice: 这个5块钱哎
Alice: This is five yuan.
Jake: 那个十一块是吧
Jake: That one is eleven yuan, right?
Alice: 那个十一
Alice: That one is eleven.
Alice: 并且两份也不太够
Alice: And two portions aren't enough.
Alice: 买个这个
Alice: Let's get this one.
Jake: 买鸡蛋了
Jake: Bought eggs.
Jake: 买了无菌蛋
Jake: Sterile eggs.
Shure: 我买了两个火锅底料
Shure: I bought two hot pot bases.
Jake: 火锅底料
Jake: Hot pot bases.
Katrina: 没有桃汁啊
Katrina: No peach juice?
Shure:  完了我们j人崩溃了
Shure: Oh no, our J guy is freaking out.
Jake: 我们好像我们我们分到了个
Jake: Seems like we got a...
Shure: 气的跳脚脚了
Shure: He's jumping with anger.
Jake: 什么奇怪的任务来着
Jake: What a weird task.
Alice: 什么
Alice: What?
Shure: 扎死人
Shure: It's killing me.
Alice: 美纹纸
Alice: Masking tape.
Katrina: 普通的品牌都没有吗
Katrina: No regular brands?
Jake:美纹纸美纹纸是什么东西
Jake: What's masking tape?
Alice:美纹纸这有吗
Alice: Do they have masking tape here?
Katrina:  美文纸美文纸
Katrina: Masking tape, masking tape.
Lucia:美纹纸这这里面能买到吗
Lucia: Can we buy masking tape here?
Jake: 美纹纸是什么东西
Jake: What's masking tape?
Katrina: 就贴墙上不留痕的那贴纸
Katrina: It's that tape that doesn't leave marks on walls.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Katrina: 要不直接上网买吧
Katrina: Maybe we should just buy it online.
Alice:再买两个
Alice: Buy two more.
Katrina: 跟那海报一起嘛嗯
Katrina: Together with that poster, yeah.
Katrina:  跟那个美纹纸很便宜
Katrina: Masking tape is cheap.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 嗯啊我觉得文具店也会有
Tasha: Yeah, I think stationery stores might have it too.
Katrina: 冰块模具还没买
Katrina: Haven't bought the ice mold yet.
Alice:要不然我们买大白菜吧
Alice: How about we buy napa cabbage instead?
Tasha: 好呀
Tasha: Sure.
Alice:然后我们把嫩的部分给它扔进去
Alice: Then we throw in the tender parts.
Tasha: 可以呀 可以
Tasha: Sure, sure.
Alice:因为它比较沉
Alice: Because it's quite heavy.
Alice:所以把它放下边
Alice: So we put it at the bottom.
Alice:这样不会把它压坏
Alice: This way it won't get squished.
Tasha: 哦这什么
Tasha: Oh, what's this?
Alice:槐花你吃过吗
Alice: Have you ever eaten locust flowers?
Tasha: 吃春菜
Tasha: I've had spring vegetables.
Alice: 对槐花你吃过吗
Alice: Yes, have you had locust flowers?
Tasha: 没有
Tasha: No.
Alice: 这可以炒可以做包子
Alice: You can stir-fry them or make buns with them.
Alice:很好吃甜甜的
Alice: They are very delicious and sweet.
Jake:啥意思啊
Jake: What do you mean?
Alice:就是这个是一种可以吃的东西
Alice: This is something edible.
Tasha: 金针菇买了吗
Tasha: Did you buy enoki mushrooms?
Alice:槐花
Alice: Locust flowers.
Alice: 买了买了
Alice: Yes, I bought them.
Jake:这为什么撒了呀
Jake: Why did this spill?
Alice:从缝里掉出来了
Alice: It fell out through the gap.
Tasha: 那你吃啊快别浪费
Tasha: Then eat it quickly, don't waste it.
Alice:不是这不能生吃
Alice: No, you can't eat this raw.
Jake:哈哈哈下毒
Jake: Haha, poisoning.
Alice: 没事不要告诉他
Alice: It's fine, don't tell him.
Alice: 让他吃也行
Alice: Let him eat it, it's okay.
Jake:那他吃了会怎么样呢
Jake: What will happen if he eats it?
Alice: 不好吃
Alice: It won't taste good.
Jake:主要是不好吃是吧
Jake: The main thing is it won't taste good, right?
Tasha: 调味料还有胡椒粉味精盐
Tasha: The seasonings include pepper powder, MSG, and salt.
Alice:盐
Alice: Salt.
Tasha: 还有盐哎
Tasha: And salt, right.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Yep.
Alice:嗯得找一个专门那啥的
Alice: We need to find a specific one.
Jake:槐花呀
Jake: Locust flowers?
Alice:你吃过吗
Alice: Have you eaten them?
Tasha: 豆芽豆芽就放在放一个清理
Tasha: Bean sprouts, bean sprouts, just put them in and clean them.
Jake:我感觉还真吃过
Jake: I think I've actually eaten them.
Alice:豆芽不可以没啥味
Alice: Bean sprouts don't have much flavor.
Tasha: 够够够
Tasha: That's enough, that's enough.
Jake:葱姜蒜有吗
Jake: Do we have green onions, ginger, and garlic?
Alice:葱姜蒜
Alice: Green onions, ginger, garlic.
Tasha: 葱姜蒜超市不送
Tasha: The supermarket doesn't deliver green onions, ginger, and garlic.
Jake:啊超市不送
Jake: Ah, the supermarket doesn't deliver?
Tasha: 会送吧怎
Tasha: They might deliver, how...
Tasha: 要葱姜蒜吗
Tasha: Do you need green onions, ginger, and garlic?
Jake:就就我们买这些东西他就会送葱姜蒜
Jake: If we buy these things, they'll deliver green onions, ginger, and garlic.
Tasha: 是啊
Tasha: Yeah.
Tasha: 够吗他送的
Tasha: Is it enough, what they deliver?
Tasha: 我只是觉得他会送
Tasha: I just think they will deliver.
Alice:葱怎么卖啊
Alice: How much are green onions?
Jake:我我我我我
Jake: I, I, I, I...
Alice:蒜
Alice: Garlic?
Jake:surprise闻所未闻
Jake: Surprise, never heard of it.
Jake:shocked
Jake: Shocked.
Tasha: 真的假的不是
Tasha: Really? No way.
Jake:不不知道
Jake: I don't know.
Jake:菜市场逛过这种超市
Jake: The market delivers, have you been to such a supermarket?
Tasha: 菜市场送不送
Tasha: Does the market deliver?
Jake: 菜市场可以送
Jake: The market can deliver.
Jake: 超市不一定
Jake: The supermarket not necessarily.
Alice:买吗
Alice: Should we buy it?
Tasha: 买吧 药 药是吗
Tasha: Buy it. Medicine? Is it medicine?
Alice:我再想想
Alice: Let me think again.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Alice:需要但是可以不用这么多
Alice: We need it, but not that much.
Alice:但是几个人啊
Alice: But how many people are there?
Tasha: 我觉得蒜和葱就一个就行了呵呵
Tasha: I think one garlic and one green onion is enough, haha.
Tasha: 这要大葱吗
Tasha: Do we need big green onions?
Tasha: 还是小葱
Tasha: Or small ones?
Alice: 姜可以不要哎
Alice: We don't need ginger.
Alice:蒜是出味的
Alice: Garlic is flavorful.
Jake:来让人过
Jake: Let people through.
Tasha: 行那那那就要着吧
Tasha: Okay, then let's get it.
Alice:哦不好意思
Alice: Oh, sorry.
Alice:看看加
Alice: Let's see, add...
Alice:呃在哪呢
Alice: Uh, where is it?
Alice:蒜葱葱也用不了那么多呀
Alice: We can't use that much garlic and green onions.
Tasha: 哎那明天有火锅的话
Tasha: Hey, if we're having hotpot tomorrow...
Tasha: 要不要买火锅底料和肉菜啊
Tasha: Should we buy hotpot base and meat and vegetables?
Jake:他们买了底料
Jake: They bought the hotpot base.
Jake:肉他们好像没买
Jake: But it seems like they didn't buy meat.
Tasha: 那要不要买肉
Tasha: Should we buy some meat?
Jake:可以买肉
Jake: We can buy some meat.
Jake: 回头对一下
Jake: Check it later.
Jake: 可以先
Jake: We can first...
Alice:那个您好我们如果买的话会送葱姜蒜
Alice: Excuse me, if we buy it, do we get green onions, ginger, and garlic?
Alice:送多少呢大概
Alice: How much do we get, roughly?
Alice:就是消费
Alice: Like, if we spend...
Alice:不会送吗不会送吗
Alice: Do we not get it? Do we not get it?
Tasha: 有的时候会员满9.9会送啊
Tasha: Sometimes, members get it if they spend over 9.9.
Alice:没有没有被送过哎
Alice: No, I've never gotten it.
Jake: 啊什么意思啊
Jake: Ah, what do you mean?
Jake: 我们还我们还满不了9.9
Jake: We haven't spent over 9.9 yet.
Tasha: 呃主要是我们没有会员啊
Tasha: Uh, mainly because we don't have a membership.
Alice:我好像有会员
Alice: I think I have a membership.
Tasha: 你有吗不知道这今天会不会送
Tasha: Do you? I don't know if we'll get it today.
Alice:哦
Alice: Oh.
Tasha: 有被送过
Tasha: Have you gotten it before?
Alice:有被送过但不一定是吧
Alice: I've gotten it before, but not always, right?
Tasha: 他好像每天
Tasha: It seems like every day...
Alice:但是这也用不了这么多
Alice: But we can't use that much anyway.
Tasha: 嗯没关系做火锅还要用的
Tasha: Hmm, it's okay, we can use it for hot pot.
Tasha: 拿着吧
Tasha: Just take it.
Alice:确实拿吧
Alice: Yeah, just take it.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Alice:嗯哼哼
Alice: Mmhmm.
Alice:你吃板栗仁吗
Alice: Do you eat chestnuts?
Alice: 可以放进去
Alice: We can add them in.
Tasha: 呃都可以
Tasha: Uh, either way is fine.
Alice: 我怕他弄不熟
Alice: I'm afraid they won't cook well.
Tasha: 那算了吧
Tasha: Then forget it.
Alice:因为这个比较难煮
Alice: Because they're hard to cook.
Alice:不过也可以放进去提前煮一下
Alice: But we can also pre-cook them a bit.
Alice:生的还是熟的
Alice: Raw or cooked?
Alice:放进去
Alice: Add them in.
Tasha: 这里呢
Tasha: Here?
Alice: 放进去吧
Alice: Add them in.
Jake:哎呀撞着了
Jake: Oops, bumped into something.
Lucia: 哎刚好碰到你们
Lucia: Oh, I just ran into you guys.
Katrina:  买完了
Katrina: Finished shopping?
Jake:你们
Jake: You guys...
Katrina:  有两个没有
Katrina: Are there two missing?
Katrina:  没有有两
Katrina: No, there are two...
Katrina: 笔没有
Katrina: There's no pen.
Alice:调料
Alice: Seasoning.
Jake: 买肉了吗
Jake: Did you buy meat?
Jake:火锅什么的他们要
Jake: They need hotpot stuff.
Katrina:  那去去买火锅的食材是吧
Katrina: So, should we go buy hotpot ingredients?
Jake:那你们去吧
Jake: Yeah, you guys go.
Alice:我们买葱蒜了
Alice: We bought green onions and garlic.
Katrina:  啊葱蒜
Katrina: Ah, green onions and garlic.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Yep.
Katrina:  那我们去买火锅食材
Katrina: Then we'll go buy hotpot ingredients.
Jake:肉在那去吧
Jake: The meat is over there, go ahead.
Tasha: 那我们的进度好慢啊他们都买完了
Tasha: Our progress is so slow, they finished shopping already.
Alice:我们比较分散呵呵
Alice: We are more spread out, haha.
Alice:不对他们还在买火锅食材呢
Alice: No, they are still buying hotpot ingredients.
Alice:调味料在哪边呢
Alice: Where are the seasonings?
Tasha: 你看那人聊天去了
Tasha: Look, that person went to chat.
Tasha: 没事
Tasha: It's fine.
Alice:在这吧但是这啊
Alice: It's here, but this...
Alice:但是奥不是这是那种
Alice: But, oh no, this is...
Alice:那是复合的那种
Alice: That's a mixed one.
Alice:调味料调味料
Alice: Seasoning, seasoning.
Alice:在这吧
Alice: It's here.
Tasha: 就这么小个柜子
Tasha: Just such a small shelf?
Alice:这不是略味鲜酱油
Alice: Isn't this Lu Wei Xian soy sauce?
Alice:感觉调味料是不是应该在这呢
Alice: Doesn't it feel like the seasoning should be here?
Alice:这是什么锅巴
Alice: What's this, Guoba?
Alice: 这已经到熟食区了
Alice: This is already the deli section.
Tasha: 这
Tasha: This.
Alice:是吗
Alice: Really?
Alice:盐
Alice: Salt.
Tasha: 加碘哪 有人不能吃碘吗
Tasha: Iodized, can anyone not eat iodine?
Alice:盐来了
Alice: Here's the salt.
Alice:碘
Alice: Iodine.
Alice:没人不能吃碘吧
Alice: No one can't eat iodine, right?
Tasha: 那 那调温量
Tasha: Then, then seasoning.
Alice:盐
Alice: Salt.
Alice:黑胡椒
Alice: Black pepper.
Alice:那有没有白胡椒呢
Alice: Do they have white pepper?
Alice:有白胡椒吧
Alice: Do we have white pepper?
Alice:辣椒粉
Alice: Chili powder.
Alice:葱姜蒜
Alice: Green onions, ginger, garlic.
Alice:买葱姜蒜还是买葱姜蒜粉呢
Alice: Should we buy green onions, ginger, garlic or the powdered version?
Tasha: 诶葱姜蒜粉好像可以啊
Tasha: Hey, the powdered version could work.
Tasha: 但是算了吧
Tasha: But forget it.
Tasha: 因为那个不是还要也要用
Tasha: Because we still need to use the regular ones.
Alice:糖你买了没
Alice: Did you buy sugar?
Alice:哦对
Alice: Oh right.
Alice:午餐肉还得
Alice: We still need luncheon meat.
Alice:午餐肉需要
Alice: We need luncheon meat.
Jake:贵4毛钱
Jake: It costs 40 cents more.
Jake: 我觉得这种比较正常
Jake: I think this one is more normal.
Jake:500 这个400克OK
Jake: 500 grams, this one is 400 grams, okay.
Tasha: 算了就这个吧
Tasha: Forget it, let's go with this one.
Jake:就这个吧
Jake: Okay, this one then.
Jake:这个棉
Jake: This is soft.
Tasha: 糖盐胡椒粉
Tasha: Sugar, salt, pepper powder.
Alice: 你得买绵白糖
Alice: You need to buy powdered sugar.
Tasha: 买了绵白糖
Tasha: I bought powdered sugar.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Tasha: 糖盐胡椒粉味精味精是吧
Tasha: Sugar, salt, pepper powder, MSG, right?
Tasha: 你还要味精这呢
Tasha: You need MSG too.
Alice:这是鸡精哦
Alice: This is chicken essence.
Alice:这个是味哦盐
Alice: This is flavor... salt.
Tasha: 喂 您
Tasha: Hey, you.
Alice:怎么是鸡精没有味精
Alice: Why do we have chicken essence and no MSG?
Tasha: 属实
Tasha: True.
Tasha: 是的
Tasha: Yes.
Alice: 怎么没有味精呢
Alice: How come there's no MSG?
Alice:午餐肉是不也用不上那么多
Tasha: 鸡精
Tasha: Chicken essence.
Tasha: 哦还是买了鸡精是吧没有味精是吧
Tasha: Oh, we bought chicken essence, no MSG, right?
Alice:没有没有味精
Alice: No, no MSG.
Alice:这差不多不过
Alice: That's about right, but...
Jake:没有味精
Jake: No MSG.
Tasha: 差不多味精和鸡精差不多
Tasha: They're almost the same, MSG and chicken essence.
Alice:味精会健康一点
Alice: MSG is a bit healthier.
Tasha: 把鸡精挑
Tasha: Pick out the chicken essence.
Alice:鸡精的添加剂多一点
Alice: Chicken essence has more additives.
Jake:哦没关系
Jake: Oh, it's fine.
Jake:活到现在了
Jake: We made it this far.
Tasha: 金针菇松花蛋娃娃菜都买了
Tasha: We bought enoki mushrooms, century eggs, and baby bok choy.
Alice: 我买过一个午餐肉
Alice: I bought a can of luncheon meat.
Alice:但我不知道够不够
Alice: But I don't know if it's enough.
Tasha: 草莓买了
Tasha: Got strawberries.
Tasha: 奶油买了
Tasha: Got cream.
Tasha: 薄荷保鲜膜
Tasha: Mint, plastic wrap.
Tasha: 蛋挞没买呢
Tasha: Didn't get egg tarts.
Alice:谁买不买呢
Alice: Who's getting them?
Alice:放进去吧
Alice: Just put it in.
Alice:扔进去
Alice: Throw it in.
Tasha: 我已经开始渴了
Tasha: I'm starting to get thirsty.
Tasha: 听到这个声音
Tasha: Hearing that sound.
Jake: 买一会喝
Jake: Buy something to drink later.
Tasha: 这买什么来着 咖啡豆
Tasha: What were we supposed to buy again? Coffee beans.
Jake:喝
Jake: Drink.
Jake:咖啡豆
Jake: Coffee beans.
Tasha: 他不知道
Tasha: He doesn't know.
Tasha: 磨咖啡要吗
Tasha: Do we need to grind the coffee?
Jake:咖啡豆在哪买
Jake: Where do we buy coffee beans?
Tasha: 不知道呀
Tasha: No idea.
Alice: 咖啡豆这不好买吧
Alice: Coffee beans aren't easy to find, right?
Tasha: 你好这里有咖啡豆卖吗
Tasha: Hello, do you sell coffee beans here?
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Yeah.
Alice:看一下
Alice: Let's check.
Alice:奶粉哦奶粉是他们买吧
Alice: Milk powder, oh, they bought the milk powder, right?
Tasha: 是吗
Tasha: Really?
Alice:奶粉是他们买吗
Alice: Did they buy the milk powder?
Alice:我们是几到几啊
Alice: What's our range?
Tasha: 我们是5-11
Tasha: We're from 5 to 11.
Alice: 那我们没有买奶粉
Alice: Then we didn't buy the milk powder.
Tasha: 没事其实奶粉不重要
Tasha: It's okay, the milk powder isn't that important.
Lucia: 吃一点
Lucia: Have a little.
Tasha: 我只想一小一小包而已
Tasha: I just wanted a small pack.
Jake:丑蛋糕他们在干嘛
Jake: What are they doing with the ugly cake?
Alice:你在找啥呀
Alice: What are you looking for?
Tasha: 咖啡豆
Tasha: Coffee beans.
Katrina: 走吧逛玩玩
Katrina: Let's go, take a stroll.
Alice:蓝胖子
Alice: Blue Fatty.
Alice: 是蓝胖子吧
Alice: It's Blue Fatty, right?
Tasha: 啊太贵了这一罐没必要
Tasha: Ah, this one is too expensive, no need to buy it.
Jake:水果麦
Jake: Fruit wheat.
Tasha: 唉 有咖啡豆 这
Tasha: Oh, there are coffee beans here.
Alice: 哎有咖啡粉
Alice: Oh, there's coffee powder.
Alice:这都有
Alice: They have everything.
Tasha: 呃
Tasha: Uh.
Tasha: 你觉得买哪个好
Tasha: Which one do you think we should buy?
Katrina: 但肉制品火锅全部都是我们买吗
Katrina: But are we buying all the meat products for the hotpot?
Tasha: 5 59
Tasha: 5 59.
Alice:咖啡豆他是要干嘛
Alice: What is he going to do with the coffee beans?
Katrina: 你们买了什么 芹菜吗
Katrina: What did you guys buy? Celery?
Tasha: 他要磨咖
Tasha: He wants to grind coffee.
Jake:买了买了
Jake: Bought it, bought it.
Alice:那这种是不是
Alice: Then is this the type...
Tasha: 这是你要的咖啡豆吗
Tasha: Is this the coffee beans you want?
Alice:还是 啊
Alice: Or...
Alice: 还是这种的
Alice: Or this kind?
Jake:这个今天是他们要做上汤娃娃菜
Jake: Today they are making the superior broth baby cabbage.
Shure:  我看了一眼其实不用买
Shure: I took a look, we actually don't need to buy it.
Jake:专门给他上汤娃娃菜搞的蔬菜
Jake: The vegetables are specifically for the superior broth baby cabbage.
Tasha: 不用买
Tasha: No need to buy it.
Shure:  就是这个有点捞
Shure: This is a bit too much.
Jake:应该没有别的菜了
Jake: There shouldn't be any other vegetables.
Katrina:  也就是说火锅下的菜跟
Katrina: So, the vegetables for the hotpot and...
Shure: 我不想买这个
Shure: I don't want to buy this one.
Jake:火锅没有菜
Jake: There's no vegetables for the hotpot.
Jake:对火锅还没有菜
Jake: Yeah, no vegetables for the hotpot.
Tasha: 那你明天带吗
Tasha: Are you bringing it tomorrow?
Katrina: 肉质都是我们挑
Katrina: We picked all the meat.
Shure: 给给你买的那个条条的那种
Shure: I bought the strips for you.
Katrina:  那我们得多加一点
Katrina: Then we need to add a bit more.
Shure: 这种的 拿了一条这种的
Shure: These kind, I got a strip of this.
Katrina:  感觉6个人不够吃哎
Katrina: Feels like it's not enough for six people.
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
这几份你们可以先看一下先
Look at these first.
Alice: 你买了吗
Alice: Did you buy it?
Shure: 我买了  啊 对
Shure: I bought it. Ah, yes.
Lucia: 你可以先看一下吗
Lucia: Can you check it first?
Tasha:这个吗 那行那我就不不拿了
Tasha: This one? Okay, then I won't take it.
Lucia: 现在买的东西
Lucia: The things we bought now...
Jake:好一会我们对一下吧
Jake: Okay, let's check it later.
Jake:等他们一起对一下
Jake: Wait until they check it together.
Jake:盘算一下
Jake: Let's calculate it.
Katrina: 还得买两盒肉哎
Katrina: We still need to buy two boxes of meat.
Jake:他们现在在套好
Jake: They are setting it up now.
Lucia: 好奇一下你们这边的东西
Lucia: Just curious about your stuff here.
Jake:他们在研究咖啡豆
Jake: They are studying the coffee beans.
Tasha: 保鲜膜
Tasha: Plastic wrap.
Alice:保鲜膜
Alice: Plastic wrap.
Jake:咖啡豆
Jake: Coffee beans.
Lucia: 我们刚才好像是拿了一盒速溶咖啡
Lucia: We just got a box of instant coffee, I think.
Shure:  我跟他跟他说了
Shure: I told him.
Jake:哦速溶但是这个就慢
Jake: Oh, instant coffee, but this one is slower.
Lucia: 嗯？有泰拉
Lucia: Huh? There's Thai tea.
Katrina: 什么呀
Katrina: What?
Shure:  咖啡豆的话
Shure: If it's coffee beans.
Lucia: 就是这个
Lucia: It's this one.
Lucia: 好久不见了 从我回国
Lucia: Long time no see, since I returned to China.
Katrina:  你们拿椰奶了吗
Katrina: Did you guys get coconut milk?
Alice:有椰子水
Alice: There's coconut water.
Lucia: mitchposticks怎么还是从德国进口了
Lucia: Why is Mitchposticks still imported from Germany?
Jake:呵呵
Jake: Haha.
Katrina:  我们拿椰子汁了吗
Katrina: Did we get coconut juice?
Alice: 你们需要吗
Alice: Do you need it?
Katrina:  我在想
Katrina: I'm thinking.
Katrina:  咖啡是不是可以兑一点椰子汁啊
Katrina: Can we mix coffee with some coconut juice?
Katrina:  生椰拿铁
Katrina: Fresh coconut latte.
Alice:椰奶吗
Alice: Coconut milk?
Katrina:  嗯但是那种大的咖啡
Katrina: Yeah, but for a large coffee.
Shure: 可以
Shure: Sure.
Katrina:  呃椰奶是不是只能放一天
Katrina: Uh, doesn't coconut milk only last for a day?
Alice:不开封的话可以放几天
Alice: If unopened, it can last a few days.
Katrina:  那就是开了那就得一天喝完呗
Katrina: So once opened, it has to be finished in a day?
Katrina:  我没看他那种小盒的椰树你知道吗
Katrina: I didn't see those small boxes of coconut milk, you know?
Katrina:  他都是大盒的椰树
Katrina: They all have big boxes of coconut milk.
Jake:螺蛳粉看到了
Jake: I saw some snail noodles.
Lucia: 那个
Lucia: That one.
Jake:真的
Jake: Really.
Katrina:  你去问一下子吧你拿
Katrina: Go ask them if you got it.
Jake:我们要对一下吗
Jake: Do we need to check it?
Lucia: 感觉可以
Lucia: I think it's fine.
Jake: 好那
Jake: Alright then.
Alice:其实那个大的你开封之后放两三天
Alice: Actually, the big one can last two or three days after opening.
Jake:那找个地方
Jake: Let's find a place.
Jake: 我们先对一下吧
Jake: Let's align first.
Katrina: 当时谁跟我说椰奶变质了会中毒
Katrina: Someone told me that spoiled coconut milk is toxic.
Lucia: 对保鲜膜可以在超市买
Lucia: Yeah, you can buy cling film at the supermarket.
Alice:确实
Alice: Indeed.
Jake:对一下我们找一个
Jake: Let's align and find one.
Katrina: 就不敢
Katrina: So I don't dare.
Alice:但是嗯嗯我一般一
Alice: But, um, usually I...
Katrina: 我确实没有看见他那小盒小盒的
Katrina: I really didn't see those small boxes.
Alice:我一般买这种大的
Alice: I usually buy the big ones.
Tasha: 买咖啡液也行 就不用咖啡粉就不用速溶咖啡调了
Tasha: Buying coffee concentrate is fine too, so you don't need instant coffee.
Alice:之后放两三天也没事
Alice: It can last two or three days.
Alice: 不用他那个变质的话会很明显
Alice: If it spoils, it'll be obvious.
Katrina: 要么直接叫外卖吧
Katrina: Or we could just order takeout.
Shure:  也行反正都都都行
Shure: That's fine, whatever works.
Katrina:  因为有两个东西买不到
Katrina: Because there are two things we can't buy.
Jake:都行都行反正我也不喝咖啡
Jake: Whatever, I don't drink coffee anyway.
Shure: 那你今天
Shure: So today...
Jake:哈哈早上不行啊
Jake: Haha, not in the morning.
Katrina: 不知道以为我们工作呢
Katrina: People might think we're working.
Katrina: 天天买这么多咖啡
Katrina: Buying so much coffee every day.
Lucia: 其实还好
Lucia: Actually, it's not that bad.
Katrina: 这个肉不够吧
Katrina: This meat isn't enough, right?
Katrina:  如果我6个人吃火锅的话
Katrina: If six of us are having hotpot...
Jake:昨天拍破蛋搞定了
Jake: We finished filming the broken egg yesterday.
Alice:肉在哪啊
Alice: Where's the meat?
Tasha: 这呢
Tasha: Here it is.
Jake:下面就是
Jake: It's down here.
Katrina: 两盒牛肉
Katrina: Two boxes of beef.
Tasha: 再买点丸子和虾滑
Tasha: Let's buy some meatballs and shrimp paste.
Katrina:  丸子买了虾滑也买了
Katrina: We bought meatballs and shrimp paste.
Katrina:  虾滑在这哦
Katrina: The shrimp paste is here.
Katrina:  我觉得还要拿两盒肉
Katrina: I think we need two more boxes of meat.
Katrina:  青菜也没买哎
Katrina: We didn't buy any vegetables.
Lucia: 我们为什么买哦
Lucia: Why did we buy...
Lucia: 哦哦蔬菜是吧
Lucia: Oh, oh, vegetables, right.
Jake:确实
Jake: Indeed.
Lucia: 蔬菜哦新到的咸鱼土豆
Lucia: Fresh vegetables, new salted fish and potatoes
Katrina:  你要吃土豆是吗
Katrina: You want to eat potatoes, right?
Jake: 土豆好土豆可以
Jake: Potatoes are good, potatoes are fine
Jake:土豆可以啊
Jake: Potatoes are fine
Lucia: 其实我也喜欢
Lucia: Actually, I like them too
Katrina: 走吧那我们蔬菜买肉跟青菜
Katrina: Let's go, we buy vegetables, meat, and greens
Jake:咱不是还有那个削土豆皮的那个
Jake: Don't we still have that potato peeler?
Tasha: 那个不是完了削土豆皮奥
Tasha: Isn't that potato peeler done for?
Tasha: 芋头没有买
Tasha: We didn't buy taro
Jake:走
Jake: Let's go
Shure: 芋头是啥啊
Shure: What's taro?
Lucia: 芋头放火锅吗
Lucia: Taro in hot pot?
Alice:芋头
Alice: Taro
Tasha: 不是芋泥
Tasha: Not taro paste
Lucia: 啊okok
Lucia: Ah, okay okay
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh
Shure: 芋泥
Shure: Taro paste
Jake:哎呀这什么东西
Jake: Oh, what's this?
Lucia: sorry没有跟上这个频道
Lucia: Sorry, I didn't keep up with the conversation
Shure: 芋泥
Shure: Taro paste
Katrina: 芋泥芋泥耶
Katrina: Taro paste, yay
Alice:芋头放火锅也很好吃
Alice: Taro in hot pot is also delicious
Tasha: 好呀
Tasha: Okay
Alice: 那个荔浦芋头
Alice: That Lipu taro
Tasha: 对我是要买荔浦芋头
Tasha: Yes, I want to buy Lipu taro
Shure: 芋芋泥能波波吗
Shure: Can taro paste be boba?
Alice: 走吧诶不对
Tasha: 好那我们的爆皮刀就有两用了
Tasha: Okay, then our peeler has two uses
Shure:  芋泥能啵啵吗
Shure: Can taro paste be boba?
Jake:哈哈哈走
Jake: Hahaha, let's go
Katrina: 哈哈少来这种
Katrina: Haha, stop that
Alice:可以
Alice: It can
Alice:咋了
Alice: What's up?
Tasha: 你想吃螺蛳粉吗
Tasha: Do you want to eat snail noodles?
Tasha: 你喜欢吃吗
Tasha: Do you like it?
Jake: 吃什么呀
Jake: Eat what?
Tasha: 这个
Tasha: This
Jake: 螺蛳粉啊
Jake: Snail noodles?
Jake:嗯呃能吃就没
Jake: Hmm, if we can eat it, then it's fine
Jake: 那么没一定要吃
Jake: We don't have to eat it
Jake: 对没那么想吃
Jake: Yeah, not really craving it.
Jake:doyouknow
Jake: Doyouknow
Alice:牵手手我们去买蔬菜吧
Alice: Let's hold hands and go buy some vegetables.
Jake:就是就是
Jake: Exactly, exactly.
Jake:没得吃可以吃一吃
Jake: If there's nothing else to eat, we can eat this.
Tasha: 谁去买蔬菜他们去买蔬菜
Tasha: Who's buying the vegetables? They are, right?
Alice:我们啊
Alice: We are.
Jake:他们他们买蔬菜
Jake: They, they are buying vegetables.
Alice:他们买过了吗
Alice: Have they bought it already?
Jake:他们买蔬菜
Jake: They are buying vegetables.
Alice:我们菜不是在那边吗
Alice: Isn't the vegetable over there?
Jake:我我对啊你们他们
Jake: I, I, yes, you guys, they...
Tasha: 他们可能先买肉吧
Tasha: Maybe they are buying meat first.
Jake: 他们买帝王蟹是吧
Jake: They are buying king crab, right?
Tasha: 这个也在资金范围内吗
Tasha: Is that within our budget?
Jake:你们买海蟹
Jake: You guys are buying sea crabs.
Jake:哈哈不不你们买海鲜吗
Jake: Haha, no, no, are you buying seafood?
Lucia: 哇哦 我可以吃这个吗
Lucia: Wow, can I eat this?
Jake: 哈哈哈打打招呼吧
Jake: Hahaha, just say hello.
Katrina: 我们的预算可以吃这个吗
Katrina: Is this within our budget?
Jake: 要不就拍一拍吧要不
Jake: How about we just take a picture?
Jake: 你好
Jake: Hello.
Katrina: 2099
Katrina: 2099.
Lucia: 扫描一下
Lucia: Scan it.
Jake: 1,699也还行吧
Jake: 1,699 is not bad, right?
Alice:您好
Alice: Hi there.
Tasha: 那来一只吧
Tasha: Let's get one.
Lucia: 真的吗可以吃吗
Lucia: Really, can we eat this?
Lucia: 哈哈哈来一只吧
Lucia: Hahaha, let's get one.
Shure:  你千万不要口嗨
Shure: Don't just talk big.
Shure:  我们会当真的好不好
Shure: We'll take it seriously, okay?
Lucia: 对对对
Lucia: Yeah, yeah.
Jake:我就说也还行
Jake: I'm just saying it's not bad.
Jake:我没多说什么
Jake: I didn't say much more.
Tasha: 有没有那个转架还是干嘛
Tasha: Do we have that turntable or something?
Jake:哈哈哈我没哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha, I didn't, hahaha.
Lucia: 也还行我们就把这个野字去掉吧啊
Lucia: Not bad, let's just drop the "wild" part, okay?
Lucia: 把还字也去掉
Lucia: And drop the "not" too.
Shure: 蘸料你们买了吗
Shure: Did you get the dipping sauce?
Lucia: 对对对我们自动识别成型
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, we automatically recognize it.
Alice:我们去找一下荔荔浦芋头吧
Alice: Let's go find some Lipu taro.
Alice:但我觉得不一定有
Alice: But I think it might be hard to find.
Jake:好好
Jake: Okay, okay.
Shure:  蘸料你们买了吗
Shure: Did you guys buy the dipping sauce?
Shure: 火锅的蘸料 那一起去买一点
Shure: The hotpot dipping sauce. Let's go buy some together.
Alice:蘸料没有
Alice: We don't have any dipping sauce.
Lucia: 没有买蘸料
Lucia: Didn't buy any dipping sauce.
Shure:  你们都吃什么碟的火锅一般
Shure: What kind of hotpot sauce do you usually eat?
Alice:麻酱
Alice: Sesame paste.
Shure: 麻酱醋麻酱
Shure: Sesame paste and vinegar, sesame paste.
Tasha: 我要醋
Tasha: I want vinegar.
Lucia: 芝麻酱
Lucia: Sesame paste.
Tasha: 你吃什么碟呢 醋碟
Tasha: What sauce do you eat? Vinegar sauce?
Alice:麻酱
Alice: Sesame paste.
Jake:呃麻酱吧
Jake: Uh, sesame paste, I guess.
Alice: 油碟
Alice: Oil sauce.
Jake:你吃什么碟
Jake: What sauce do you eat?
Tasha: 你背叛了江苏人
Tasha: You betrayed Jiangsu people.
Jake:其实我在江苏都没怎么吃过火锅
Jake: Actually, I didn't eat much hotpot in Jiangsu.
Jake:我都是上了大学才
Jake: I only started in college.
Jake:你是醋碟吗
Jake: Do you use vinegar sauce?
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yes.
Tasha: 我们不应该都和喝恒硕香醋长大的吗
Tasha: Didn't we all grow up with Hengshuo vinegar?
Jake:但是江苏但是
Jake: But in Jiangsu, but...
Shure:  杨老板吃什么
Shure: What does Jake eat?
Jake:呃就麻将吧
Jake: Uh, just sesame paste, I guess.
Jake:或者当回江苏人吧
Jake: Or maybe I'll be a Jiangsu person again.
Jake:要不吃醋碟也行
Jake: Or I could eat vinegar sauce too.
Alice:这是熟食了
Alice: This is cooked food.
Tasha: 对应该在那吧
Tasha: Yeah, it should be over there.
Lucia: 也可以其实火锅还挺省钱的
Lucia: Actually, hotpot can be quite economical.
Lucia: 嗯只要一堆食材往里一煮就好了哈
Lucia: Yeah, just throw a bunch of ingredients in and cook them, haha.
Alice: 哎呦
Alice: Oh no.
Jake: 买点方便面吧
Jake: Let's buy some instant noodles.
Jake: 算了算了哈哈哈
Jake: Forget it, forget it, haha.
Katrina:  后面两天经费不足
Katrina: We're short on budget for the next two days.
Katrina:  天天方便面
Katrina: Instant noodles every day.
Tasha: 你觉得芋头会在哪有呢
Tasha: Where do you think we can find taro?
Alice:芋头
Alice: Taro.
Alice:问一下那个啥吧
Alice: Let's ask someone.
Alice: 刚没看见反正
Alice: I didn't see it just now anyway.
Alice: 这种是不是也可以涮火锅
Alice: Can we use this for hotpot too?
Alice:这种魔芋之类的
Alice: This kind of konjac stuff.
Tasha: 啊对豆豆制品
Tasha: Oh yeah, bean products.
Tasha: 但是他们会不会买豆制品呢
Tasha: But do they buy bean products?
Alice: 不知道那
Alice: No idea.
Tasha: 那那那我觉得要来一个豆腐
Tasha: Then, I think we should get some tofu.
Jake:豆腐
Jake: Tofu.
Jake:包浆豆腐
Jake: Fermented tofu.
Alice: 我需要魔芋
Alice: I need konjac.
Tasha: 你喜欢吃这种干豆腐还是吃
Tasha: Do you like this dry tofu or...
Alice:内酯豆腐
Alice: Silken tofu.
Tasha: 内酯豆腐
Tasha: Silken tofu.
Tasha: 这个呢浆水豆腐哎
Tasha: How about this fermented tofu?
Jake:这都什么差别
Jake: What's the difference?
Jake: 这个这个一般
Jake: This one is just okay.
Jake:我感觉这个有点硬
Jake: I feel like this one is a bit hard.
Alice:就是那种老豆腐
Alice: It's that kind of firm tofu.
Tasha: 那就这种吧
Tasha: Then let's go with this one.
Jake:啊可以
Jake: Ah, okay.
Jake:看起来不错
Jake: Looks good.
Tasha: 鲜豆腐 豆腐皮呢
Tasha: Fresh tofu. How about tofu skin?
Alice:魔芋你要吃那种
Alice: Do you want to eat that kind of konjac?
Tasha: 魔芋
Tasha: Konjac.
Alice:对
Alice: Yeah.
Tasha: 这个魔芋好奇怪
Tasha: This konjac is so weird.
Alice:这魔芋就是这种的
Alice: This konjac is just like this.
Tasha: 有没有魔芋丝
Tasha: Do they have konjac noodles?
Alice:魔芋丝
Alice: Konjac noodles.
Tasha: 魔芋丝魔芋丝或者魔芋皮都行
Tasha: Konjac noodles or konjac skin, either one.
Tasha: 行吧
Tasha: Alright.
Alice: 就这几种
Alice:买这种吧
Alice: Let's buy this one.
Alice:这种比较原生
Alice: This one is more natural.
Tasha: 行那再拿个这个吧
Tasha: Okay, then let's get this one too.
Alice:3块9可以
Alice: 3.9 yuan is okay.
Alice: 买这个金针菇吧这个便宜
Alice: Let's buy these enoki mushrooms, they're cheap.
Alice:: 呃把这个有机的给它放回去
Alice: Uh, put the organic ones back.
Jake:哈哈哈对
Jake: Haha, yeah.
Jake: 咱就不要那么有机了
Jake: Let's not go too organic.
Alice: 这有娃娃菜吗
Alice: Do you have baby bok choy?
Alice: 让我找找
Alice: Let me look for it.
Jake:哎你问的好
Jake: Hey, good question.
Alice:没有
Alice: Nope.
Tasha: 我找到了芋头
Tasha: I found taro.
Tasha: 但是不是荔浦芋头咋办
Tasha: But it's not Lipu taro, what should we do?
Alice:不是荔浦芋头
Alice: It's not Lipu taro.
Alice: 打出来的不细腻
Alice: The texture won't be as smooth.
Alice:是那个味道
Alice: It's that taste.
Tasha: 好小啊
Tasha: It's so small.
Alice: 这种芋头
Alice: This kind of taro.
Alice:嗯只只适合那个啥
Alice: Yeah, it's only suitable for certain things.
Alice:问一下吧
Alice: Let's ask around.
Tasha: 吃烤地瓜吗
Tasha: Want to eat roasted sweet potatoes?
Alice:没有烤箱是吧
Alice: We don't have an oven, right?
Alice: 也可以
Alice: We could still do it.
Alice: 买那种烟薯
Alice: Buy those smoked sweet potatoes.
Tasha: 我也这么觉得吧
Tasha: I think so too.
Alice: 这种板栗的也可以
Alice: These chestnut ones are good too.
Tasha: 嗯但这种吃起来有点沙
Tasha: Yeah, but these have a bit of a sandy texture.
Alice: 都挺好吃的
Alice: They're all pretty tasty.
Tasha: 我想哎
Tasha: I think, hey.
Tasha: 烟薯地瓜
Tasha: Smoked sweet potatoes.
Tasha: 这个可以
Tasha: These are good.
Alice:这个
Alice: This one.
Tasha: 你觉得买几个
Tasha: How many do you think we should buy?
Alice:至少至少买一个大的吧
Alice: At least buy one big one.
Alice: 这个小的
Alice: This small one.
Tasha: 他们这种大的可以切小一点
Tasha: They can cut the big ones into smaller pieces.
Tasha: 买这个吧
Tasha: Let's buy this one.
Alice:一大包的
Alice: A big pack.
Alice:小一点的
Alice: Smaller ones.
Alice: 这个这种的好熟
Tasha:蜜薯也可以
Tasha: Honey sweet potatoes are good too.
Alice:蜜薯更甜
Alice: Honey sweet potatoes are sweeter.
Alice:哦两个都挺好吃的
Alice: Oh, both are pretty tasty.
Alice: 不一样的好吃
Alice: Different kinds of tasty.
Tasha: 我觉得蜜薯好吃点吧
Tasha: I think honey sweet potatoes taste better.
Alice: 葱姜蒜组合
Alice: Green onion, ginger, garlic combo.
Tasha: 有荔浦芋头吗
Tasha: Do you have Lipu taro?
Alice: 大的芋头
Alice: Big taro.
Alice:啊那种也可以
Alice: Ah, that kind is fine too.
Alice:可以可以可以
Alice: Sure, sure, sure.
Alice: 冻一下子更粉
Alice: Freeze it a bit, it gets more powdery.
Tasha: 我觉得还冻一下子冻一下还懒得切了
Tasha: I think if we freeze it a bit, we might be too lazy to cut it.
Alice:冻一下子更好吃
Alice: Freezing it makes it tastier.
Tasha: 是吗没关系我主要在这个
Tasha: Really? It's fine, I'm mostly focused on this.
Tasha: 就没看到没削皮的
Tasha: I just didn't see any unpeeled ones.
Alice: 荔浦芋头
Alice: Lipu taro.
Tasha:那人呢车呢
Tasha: So where are the people and the cars?
Alice:没事待会再偶遇吧
Alice: No worries, we'll run into them later.
Alice:诶 那你荔浦芋头要做芋圆吗
Alice: Hey, are you making taro balls with that Lipu taro?
Tasha: 对芋呃芋泥
Tasha: Yeah, taro... uh, taro paste.
Alice: 那你要做芋圆吗
Alice: Then are you making taro balls?
Alice:我可以帮你揉
Alice: I can help you knead it.
Alice:我特别喜欢揉的那个
Alice: I really love kneading that stuff.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Alice:唉小心点
Alice: Hey, be careful.
Lucia: 好嘞
Lucia: Got it.
Alice:然后那个荔浦芋头也可以涮火锅
Alice: And then that Lipu taro can also be used for hot pot.
Tasha: 嗯可以啊
Tasha: Yeah, sure.
Alice:如果我们能买的话
Alice: If we can buy it.
Alice: 买个大块的也可以
Alice: Buying a big piece is fine too.
Tasha: 可以买两个大块的
Tasha: We can buy two big pieces.
Alice:没事如果红红薯吃不完的话
Alice: No worries, if we can't finish the sweet potatoes.
Alice:做成红薯芋啊
Alice: Turn them into sweet potato taro.
Alice: 不是有那个紫薯粉吗
Alice: Isn't there that purple sweet potato powder?
Tasha: 紫薯粉是用来加颜色的
Tasha: The purple sweet potato powder is for adding color.
Alice:是
Alice: Yes.
Tasha: 他们去干啥去了
Tasha: What are they up to?
Alice:就这个荔浦芋头没什么颜色
Alice: This Lipu taro doesn't have much color.
Jake:找你们去了
Jake: Looking for you guys.
Tasha: 烤地瓜吗
Tasha: Roasted sweet potatoes?
Jake:烤就放烤箱
Jake: Just put them in the oven.
Alice: 放吧另一个呢
Alice: Sure, what about the other one?
Tasha: 另什么另一个
Tasha: Which other one?
Jake:放烤箱是吧
Jake: Put it in the oven, right?
Tasha: 噢噢烟薯是吗
Tasha: Oh, oh, the smoked sweet potato, right?
Jake:土豆
Jake: Potatoes.
Tasha: 好吧我想吃
Tasha: Alright, I want to eat them.
Jake: 有土豆吗
Jake: Do we have potatoes?
Jake: 我不用我不用
Jake: I don't need them, I don't need them.
Jake:我乱说的
Jake: I was just kidding.
Jake:因为刚刚不是提到了吗
Jake: Because we just mentioned it.
Alice:啊有的有的
Alice: Oh, we have some.
Alice:两个
Alice: Two.
Jake:给你加俩土豆
Jake: I'll add two potatoes for you.
Jake:耶
Jake: Yay.
Tasha: 你只要爱吃土豆对你就可以加入
Tasha: As long as you love eating potatoes, you can join us.
Tasha: 申请加入我们土门
Tasha: Apply to join our "Potato Clan".
Jake:你是土豆
Jake: You are a potato.
Tasha: 呃只需要交298元一年
Tasha: Uh, you just need to pay 298 yuan a year.
Jake:为啥这是什么门
Jake: Why? What kind of clan is this?
Alice:会员费
Alice: Membership fee.
Jake:每天都可以吃土豆吗
Jake: Can I eat potatoes every day?
Jake:呃有什么
Jake: Uh, what about...
Tasha: 是的
Tasha: Yes.
Tasha: 只要看见我就可以吃
Tasha: As long as you see me, you can eat.
Jake:土豆夹子哦
Jake: Potato clip?
Tasha: 你跟他们说我们买了土豆
Tasha: Tell them we bought potatoes.
Tasha: 还有豆制品豆腐什么
Tasha: And soybean products like tofu.
Tasha: 豆腐的都买了
Tasha: We bought tofu too.
Alice: 买了魔芋
Alice: We bought konjac.
Lucia: 我们也买了豆腐好像
Lucia: We also bought tofu, I think.
Alice:买了什么豆腐
Alice: What kind of tofu did we buy?
Shure:  豆腐什么
Shure: What tofu?
Shure:  4拼这种豆制品拼盘
Shure: A four-piece tofu platter.
Alice:哦不一样的东西
Alice: Oh, different stuff.
Katrina: 你这个你这个是做什么的啊
Katrina: What is this for?
Tasha: 你这个是干的
Tasha: This one is dried.
Tasha: 这是鲜的啊
Tasha: This one is fresh.
Katrina: 就是放火锅里吃吗
Katrina: Is it for hotpot?
Tasha: 鲜豆腐
Tasha: Fresh tofu.